[Music]
hey there
nice of you to check out this video on
the ai coffee break channel that just
surpassed 500 subscribers
crazy miss coffee bean and me still
cannot believe it
this channel that started first as a
creative and playful spin-off to my
semester of teaching in corona mode
now has so many subscribers that follow
the content regularly
this is 20 times as many people than i
have thought in one semester
and on youtube we can explain things to
the whole globe and do this even when
i am sleeping because miss coffee bean
does the whole
explaining thank you all for joining us
in our humble beginnings
miss coffeebean will do her best not to
disappoint you in the future
okay enough of this we get to the topic
of today's video
this video is taking a breathing pause
after miss coffee bean is quite
overwhelmed with
recent advances like gpt3 in machine
learning
especially in natural language
processing or short nlp
so if you feel a little overwhelmed too
let's take a top-down theoretical view
on the whole situation of data-driven
language models
in this video we will address three
important questions
what is meaning how far is
state-of-the-art in nlp from meaning
and do publications please use the word
meaning
especially we are discussing the paper
of emily bender
and alexander collar this is not only
miss coffee bean's favorite paper of the
month
but it won the best themed paper award
at acl 2020
for the theme of the conference taking
stock of where we've been and where
we're going
even though this video is about nlp we
think that there are important messages
that everyone in ai should think about
the paper delivers theoretical
considerations about
what the language model trained purely
on text completion
can learn about meaning what is meaning
well wait for it we will come to that
later now we ask
how often have you heard academic
publications news or even miss coffee
bean
say that large language models
especially transformer architectures
like gpt3 or bird
understand natural language and learn
meaning
far too often to be honest and in miss
coffee beans defense
she also puts it like this from time to
time trying to
simplify things and deliver messages
quickly
otherwise she's afraid she might be
spending too much time on defining
appropriate terms or opening a
philosophical discussion about how far
we are on the ladder towards natural
language understanding
but now there is no more way around this
it is time to discuss this with the help
of this paper
and at least warn that words like
meaning
and understanding can be very easily
misused and misinterpreted
when we are talking about language
models like bird or gpd
and this leads to an undesirable
mismatch between what research tells it
does and what it really does
so the author's right we argue that the
language modeling task because it only
uses form
as training data can not in principle
lead to
learning of meaning this is a very
strong claim to accept
especially if you have seen bird perform
magic on biology data
or seen gpt3 translate
make copycat analogies and many other
things
but wait a little what does this claim
even mean
we will not be on the same page until we
have explained the terminology
so it is time for the terminology taser
it is very important to define what a
language model is
with language models the authors quote
refer to any system trained only on the
task of string prediction
whether it operates over characters
words or sentences
and sequentially or not end quote
so bird predicting masked words or
tokens in sentences
is definitely falling into the category
of a language model
now what does meaning mean quote
we take linguistic meaning to be the
relation between a linguistic form and
communicative intent
wait what have we just explained the
term with two
other ones yeah but don't worry because
we are at the terminology button here to
get away from the range of the
terminology taser
we will now build an example based on
alice and
bob talking to each other alice is
hungry
and she wants bob to bring her food this
is her communicative intent she wants
him to get her food
but for bob to get a message alice needs
to realize her communicative intent
into a form or into something
in the real world this could be
imperative air vibrations that bob ears
perceive as alice's commanding voice
get me food the trace of pen
on paper the pixels of this video or the
hands and the face in science languages
now for bob to get a message he has to
understand
the meaning so he has to find out the
right combination of all possible pairs
of expressions and
intents that alice could have notice
that bob does
not have access to the communicative
intent but
only to the form then if he gets the
right meaning of the form without access
to the communicative intent
he has an understanding of the situation
but he has to be careful because the
meaning of alice's get me food
expression
is not to be confused with the many
conventional meanings
to alice's expression for example she
might have said
get me food as a request for something
to eat or she might just have wanted bob
to bring her their dog called
food this is not a conventional meaning
of food you might say
well keep in mind that this is only the
term for describing all potential
meanings of an expression
the conventional meaning does not have
to be neither widely accepted nor in any
dictionary
think about you and your best friend
inventing words or using words as a code
this meaning is in no dictionary but you
both know what that utterance means
but just imagine the gap between form
and meaning
is bigger than one things because the
number of communicative intents is huge
we as humans cheat a little because we
have access to the physical
social or mental situation of our
interlocutor
for the language model so a system that
was trained only on strings to do string
completion
does not and while humans given a form
try really hard to make a mental model
of the communicative intent of the
interlocutor and
understand the meaning a language model
never does
it gets the form and compute
similarities and likelihoods to other
forms
that have to be the right response
without building a model of the
communicative intent
and this one is crucial in the relation
between form and meaning
so the authors argue that quote the
language modeling task
because it only uses form as training
data can not in principle lead to
learning of meaning
yes so what gpt 3 is still performing
like it would know a lot about the world
well it seems like quote their apparent
ability to reason is sometimes a mirage
built on leveraging artifacts in the
training data
so on form not meaning end quote
all that the language model has seen is
an enormous amount of utterances about
the world
but it does not seek clues from the
communicative intent
and it also doesn't try to model it to
put it another way
would you expect a child to learn what
language means
if it did not interact with the world at
all but hear a recorded tape and trying
to repeat the words
to make this even more clear the authors
propose
an octopus thought experiment miss
coffee bean retells it now with minor
alterations
once upon a later time we have again
alice and bob
now separated on two different islands
because
bob did not succeed in bringing alice
food
but because they still miss each other
they are sending messages to each other
through an underwater cable only
that mr o this octopus
is super intelligent and has tapped into
their communication line
of course mr o does not speak english
but
over time he learns patterns and can
predict what bob's responses to alice
are
and start sending messages to alice
instead of bob
alice does not notice the exchange since
mr o is getting really good at his
impersonation
he can even realize that some words are
used in similar context
and can be exchanged if needed can
construct whole plausible sentences
only that mr o has never seen the
objects that alice and bob are talking
about
because their communication is kind of
regular this is enough for the while
when not much changes on alice's and
bob's islands
but one day alice says that she invented
the coconut catapult
and sends the building plan to bob mr o
intercepts the message but
can not rebuild the invention because he
does not know what ropes or
coconuts are but from earlier
conversations he noticed that bob would
react with very excited like this
great job did he really understand what
the coconut catapult is and what it is
for
no he did not grasp the communicative
intent of alice
because he misses important observations
about her world
happy with mr oath's reply impersonating
bob
alice asks what should i use the coconut
catapult for
should i use it for sending you coconuts
to your island or
should i use it to defend against this
bear lurking in the bush
well mr o has a problem now
not knowing how to respond what is the
friction coefficient of air how does
gravity without the archimedes force
works
how far are the islands apart how much
does bob want a coconut
he would not even get this far with the
questions because what is a coconut and
what is a catapult in the first place
all he knows is that coconuts are used
in the context of food
and catapults are used in the context of
defending
but can coconuts defend against a bear
can coconuts fly from island to island
mr o had a great time impersonating bob
but now he has to admit his defeat
the allegory of mr o was meant to
clarify that language models are in mr
oh's situation
so what to do we have to keep in mind
that
all arguments so far hold only for
language models
so systems that are trained to predict
missing strings in a sequence
we can also think about new tasks and
data sets that are augmented with
meaning
for example about those that try to
ground language in a visual situation
for more on this check out our video
linked right now and also in the
description below
also that a language model does not
require meaning
does not mean that bird does not deliver
amazing results
this paper tries to set a warning sign
that reveals what meaning
is how far state-of-the-art systems are
from meaning
and how publications misuse the word
meaning
in a field where after gpt 2 comes gpt 3
with even more impressive results
by only being trained on language
modeling we have to take a break
to think about what the system lets
us think it can do and what it can
really do
because we didn't address all aspects of
the paper
miss coffee bean really recommends you
to read the paper yourself
or even have the authors read it out
loud for you links to the paper into
soundcloud are in the description below
let us know in the comments what you
think this is kind of a controversial
and upsetting topic
and it might need some time for
digestion thanks for watching patiently
until the end
see you next time bye
[Music]